recuerdo cuando se era chico
y estaba en el club
por fuera el futuro con mis amigos
llegaba la hora del pan y el queso para
seleccionar los equipos
para los más chicos
les cuento que el pan y el queso era la
forma más democrática de
elegir y seleccionar el equipo
en el cual el ganador
elegí a primero y el perdedor elegía
después y así sucesivamente
estaba claro que el primero en ser
elegido iba a ser el que mejor jugaba
y en esta orden de sucesión
el último ser elegido
y va a ser el que peor jugaba el más
malo de todos y él tiene muchas veces
nadie lo quería en su equipo
yo temblaba
rodada por dentro no será el último
porque eso significaba que mis amigos
no querían conmigo
que era malo
y que en este pequeño desafío que me
había propuesto había fracasado
seguramente muchos habemos vivenciado de
esa situación
y hoy al ver que le puede pasar a mi
hijo porque le puede pasar a los chicos
me hace reflexionar y no hace cuestionar
nuestro propio accionar
cuántas veces nos queremos
y podemos hacer un juicio de valor
clasificando el desempeño del otro como
exitoso o fracasado
y desde qué lugar lo hacemos que nos da
el grado de poder
para poder definir
la calidad lo que hace la otra persona
saben que decirle a una persona y más
si hablamos de los más pequeños que es
malo para un deporte que no sirve para
una actividad o para practicarlo
deriva en un abandono prematuro de la
actividad
y que tendrá una gran sensación de
fracaso con una gran limitación
emocional para poder practicarlo durante
el resto de sus vidas
hay quienes tienen las herramientas y el
entorno necesario
para poder superarlo
pero hay muchos otros que no
saben la cantidad de veces que en la en
lo cotidiano
hacemos o hicimos juicios de valor a
otro
o en situaciones como diciéndole yo en
tu lugar haría tal y tal cosa
sin saber
cuál fue el proceso que tránsito hasta
llegar ahí
sin saber de dónde viene sin saber su
historia
sin saber sus virtudes sus miedos
pero nosotros siempre jugamos
juzgamos
o proyectamos los que nos gustaría poder
hacer y nunca nos animamos
seguramente todos tengamos
en nuestra vida historias de éxito y
fracaso
y aunque para los demás podrían ser
pequeñas historias de éxito y fracaso
para nosotros eran grandes historias de
éxito y fracaso
cuanta vez se nos pasó
en donde éramos los exitosos los
ganadores
o los fracasados
en un partido en un deporte en un juego
o en el colegio mismo al sacar la nota
más alta o la más baja de la clase
creo que todos inconsciente o
conscientemente
a lo largo de nuestras vidas nos hemos
acercado a personas por su éxito por
ejemplo al compañero que era el que el
ibavi de los deporte que siempre salía
campeón quería bien en el colegio
lo admirábamos lo idolatra vamos
solo por el hecho de ser talentoso
ganador
éxitos
caso contrario
era con el carente de talento
el cual era el último en ser elegido en
el pan el queso
era blanco de algunas burlas
o directamente lo evita vamos
en nuestra vida cotidiana
seguramente alguno de los presentes fue
el primer caso
el talentoso el exitoso
pero también creo que la mayoría de los
que estamos acá nos podemos llegar a
identificar con el segundo caso
con el que éramos los últimos
en ser elegidos
que alguna vez
se burlaron de nosotros
los que directamente nos evitaban
en cualquiera de los dos casos que nos
encontremos
nuestra soberbia personal nos hace
querer
que podemos criticar y enjuiciar al
resto
suena fuerte
pero si lo pensamos vamos a ver que más
habitual de lo que nosotros creemos en
nuestra vida cotidiana
en nuestra sociedad uno de los mayores
exponentes de éxito y fracaso es el
deporte
el bendito deporte que creemos que es
tan bueno y tan sano para todos nosotros
pero veamos cuál es nuestro
comportamiento ante el rendimiento de
los deportistas en las competencias
les pedimos que sean rápidos
que sean ágiles que tengan buen estado
físico
que cabeceen que salten que hagan goles
que corran que defiendan
qué tal
les pedimos que declaren bien ante la
prensa que sean buenos padres
que sean ejemplos de vida que sean
ganadores y que sean exitosos
le pedimos casi todo lo que nosotros no
pudimos lograr
no creen que es mucho
no creen que deberíamos resignificar
en nuestra vida cotidiana este mandato
social
que heredamos y transmitimos sobre lo
que es el éxito y el fracaso
tan metido lo tenemos el tener que ser
exitosos
por ejemplo
qué es lo que le preguntamos a un chico
que viene de hacer algún deporte o jugar
al fútbol
cómo te fue
jugaste bien ganaron hiciste algún gol
salieron campeones
estamos constantemente buscando la
aprobación el ganar el ser mejor el ser
exitoso
pero pocas son las veces que les
preguntamos cómo la pasaste
lo disfrutaste la pasaste bien te
divertiste
aprendiste algo nuevo
y existe algún amigo nuevo
muchas veces más allá del resultado
obtenido no hacemos una verdadera
valoración del proceso
y es ahí en donde me quiero detener en
el proceso
es lo que mayor tiempo transitamos es el
que mayor tiempo nos lleva
es lo cotidiano
muchas veces necesariamente rutinario
es el que nos genera el hábito es el que
nos transforma
es donde vivimos nuestros mejores y
nuestros peores momentos
es el que nos hace llegar a ese límite
que muchas veces pensamos que no
podíamos alcanzar
es el que nos da y forja el carácter
es el que nos hace creer en nosotros
cualquier escena de dudas
cuántas veces nos pasó
en situaciones por ejemplo qué
previo a una competencia posterior a una
competencia o previo
después de rendir una materia en la
facultad al terminar el secundario o al
recibirnos de algún título y hacemos una
valoración de ese tiempo transcurrido al
apoyo de la familia
a las horas sacada a nuestros hijos a
nuestras parejas a nuestros amigos
eso
es el proceso lo que transitamos para
poder cumplir el objetivo nuevamente más
allá del resultado
hace alrededor de 11 años que me dedico
al running como profesor aunque en mi
deporte formativo de toda la vida fue y
es el rugby
uno de los puntos en común que tiene
estas dos disciplinas es que se las
entiende como extremadamente
democráticas dado que en el rugby
pueden participar todo tipo de personas
más allá de su contextura física por
ejemplo el ranking pueden jugar el alto
el petiso el grandote el chiquito
el rápido el lento
el track hito el no tan flaquito
el talentoso
y el ojo está
si escucharon bien el ojo está el ojo
está es ese que dicen que no sirve para
ningún deporte pero que muchas veces es
el que más gana le pone
y muchas veces es el que mejor entiende
y valora lo que es el proceso
el reiki es un deporte en equipo
en el cual cada uno tiene un rol que
cumplir por el bien del mismo
en el running a diferencia del rugby es
un deporte individual pero tiene una
gran participación grupal en donde el
objetivo está en ser protagonista y no
mirar
y lo pongo como ejemplo
porque al practicarlo junto con mis
alumnos durante tantos años veo lo que
esto genera en ellos
por ejemplo en una carrera
pueden una carrera no importa la
distancia pueden ser 5 10 15 21 ó 42
kilómetros pueden llegar a participar
10.000 personas
una sea primero
9999 ganan
ganan por el solo hecho de haber estado
en la línea de salida y haber cruzado el
arco de llegada por eso en las carreras
se le da medalla a todos los que
participan y finalizan la prueba
y si hay lo que verdaderamente me gusta
mucho del running y de las carreras es
que generalmente las dos personas más
aplaudidas son el primero
y el último
el primero porque sin duda fue el más
rápido del día gran mérito tiene
y el último
porque fue el resultado porque cumplió
con su objetivo que fue el resultado de
su pequeño gran proceso más allá de la
clasificación general
por eso cuando mis alumnos muchas veces
me dicen que ellos no quieren llegar
últimos en las carreras yo siempre les
digo que nos llegan últimos que siempre
van a llegar delante de los que se
quedaron afuera mirando como ellos
corrían
es un ejemplo a valorar
lo que transitaron de dónde vienen y lo
que lograron
sí o sí
la valoración en este tipo y transitar
en este tipo de disciplina son de suma
importancia porque con orden
y perseverancia
las ganancias tarde o temprano llega
se ven se palpan
se sienten
lo que parecía lejano se acercó
pero que parecía imposible es posible
lo que queríamos que nunca podía pasar
pasa
y eso es para mí el éxito hacer que las
cosas sucedan nuevamente más allá del
resultado y si por alguna circunstancia
que pueden ser muchas no llegamos a
cumplir el objetivo no será un fracaso
sino que nos servirá para rever el
proceso saber que debemos ajustar y por
sobre todo saber si el objetivo que nos
planteamos era apto para nosotros o no
qué bueno sería poder tomar parte de
todas estas enseñanzas que no va al
deporte y poder aplicarlas en nuestra
vida cotidiana es decir ser los
protagonistas no juzgarnos por el tiempo
que nos llevan las cosas y valorar
nuestros pequeños grandes procesos
porque lo que para uno es un gran éxito
para el otro es un fracaso
y para lo que uno es un fracaso
para el otro es un éxito
esta dicotomía siempre estuvo está y
estará y siempre va a depender de quién
lo mire y cómo lo verá
el deporte
nos enseña
a esforzarnos
a respetarnos a cumplir las reglas
a jugar limpio y por sobre todo a
unirnos más allá de las diferencias en
tiempos
en donde la sociedad tiende a dividirse
cada vez más y más
el deporte como actividad es el proceso
que nos transforma en personas más
íntegras más solidarias más respetuosas
y más empáticas
y que nos ayuda a comprender
que el éxito y el fracaso son sólo
pequeñas partes de este gran proceso que
es nuestra vida muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]